I push myself to the limit every day
I know I want to achieve I know how hard
it is to achieve it
and I think the motivation comes from
trying to make myself better every
single day
the feeling of crossing the line ahead
of your competition
and to never give up on something that's
what motivates me to carry on sport as
always seems to be decided by the
narrowest of margins I've won and lost
major medals by tiny split seconds and
as athletes you're always trying to find
the edge the tiny differences will make
you win on and be the right side of
those fine margins we have to be on top
of everything we do on the water
technically but also everything we do to
ensure with performing at our peak
physically as well the nutrition is a
massive part of that you want to make
yourself as busy can be as strong as you
can be as fast it can be you have to
recover as fast as possible to get on to
the next training session and to give
your body the best chance of keeping out
there and drink it through the work for
putting it through what fuels me the
challenge of it the challenge every day
fuels me